[Music]
all right I wanted to do something a
little different this week and catch you
guys up on some Insider stuff going on
over here at the Ruben report first off
I just want to say how pleased we are
not only with the growth of the show in
terms of numbers but also in terms of
the content that we're putting out every
week we're on track to crack 500,000
subscribers in just a couple weeks and
our watch time is about 15 minutes per
video which is pretty much unheard of on
YouTube
our audience engagement is also equally
great and even the comment section right
here on YouTube hasn't totally devolved
into the abyss of hate like so many
other channels have more importantly
though I'm incredibly proud of the
conversations we're continuing to Foster
around here from last week's interview
with ion hery Ali to the week before
with Jordan Peterson and before that
with Yasmin mohammd and Brandon Turner I
think we've managed to have wide-
ranging important conversations which
leave you with something to think about
instead of feeling empty and enraged
like so much content out there is
designed to make you
feel many of you have asked me about the
YouTube demonetization issue which I've
addressed a bit on Twitter and Facebook
but I wanted to discuss here as well for
those of you just catching up about 6
weeks ago YouTube lost about $750
million in ad sales after a bunch of
stories ran across mainstream media
about how ads were being played on
offensive content on the YouTube
platform putting aside what's actually
offensive or that you rarely associate
the ad playing before the video with the
content itself YouTube found itself in a
tough spot 750 million isn't chump
change even to a company like Google and
suddenly there were less ads to go
around the entire platform I should
pause here and say that as a private
company of course YouTube absolutely has
the right to do whatever they want with
their business and in this case if there
aren't ads to go around on all the
content well nobody's forcing me or
anyone else to create videos here at the
same time this demonetization was
happening there was also another problem
unfolding for channel such as this one
some of our videos which deal with
certain controversial topics aren't
getting served ads at all so for example
videos we've done with people from
Lauren Southern to Bishop Baron to
Yasmin Muhammad there's some real
diversity in that group aren't being
served ads due to the nature of their
content again that is within YouTube's
right to do and it isn't censorship
because they aren't stopping us from
putting up those interviews but
eventually every creator has to make a
dime creators will eventually
self-censor if they know that certain
topics won't make them any money since I
try to be as transparent as possible
with you I want to tell you a little bit
more about how our Economics work around
here our interview with ion her Al which
was done on location in another city due
to security issues cost us over $5,000
between Studio rent flying my crew to
another City hotel rooms and some other
ancillary costs the four videos that we
put up with ion have made us less than
,000 back on YouTube I'm no Economist
but even I know that that's not a
sustainable business model in this case
not doing the interview with ion would
have been The Prudent business decision
but of course I'm thrilled and honored
that ion took the time and in my view it
was worth the financial hit we took to
make it happen the truly that ion speaks
about female genital mutilation the
left's alliance with Islam and the power
of the individual as a lynchpin in a
free and Western Society are all
messages that I think must be heard and
must be Amplified I'll continue to have
those important conversations regardless
of the financial implications as long as
we can possibly do so I mention all of
this Insider stuff to you not for your
pity or even for your money but just to
give you a little insight into how
complex content creation is these days
and how there are often behind the
scenes issues that have little to do
with the content but a lot to do with
how we're able to make it so I'll end
this with another thank you to all of
you who've continued to support us via
monthly pledges on patreon or through
onetime pledges on PayPal you guys are
the ones who make it possible to do this
show and allow us to make decisions
based on the conversations that we want
to have without solely looking at the
bottom line we're going to continue to
find new partners to work with and other
out of the-box ways to monetize our
content but without you we simply
couldn't do what we do around here all
right so enough business let's get back
to the conversation joining me today is
brijit Gabriel breit is the founder of
act for America the country's largest
Grassroots National Security
Organization she has an incredibly
fascinating personal story of growing up
as a Christian in Lebanon during their
Civil War and is now a strident defender
of women minorities and Western values
will our videos be monetized on YouTube
well there's only one way to find
[Music]
out joining me today is a New York Times
bestselling author a national security
expert and founder of act for America
briet Gabriel welcome to the Reuben
report thank you I'm so delighted to be
with you I am delighted to be with you
what an honor what an honor do you know
that just the two of us sitting down
before we even say anything is going to
trigger a lot of people there's going to
be some outraged people just because
we're sitting here before we've even
said
anything hey you know what if you can't
cause problems while you go through life
you're not doing something right indeed
so you have caused some problems for
some people I find you to be on the
right side of most stuff and someone
that's doing it with a bit of a sense of
humor and uh and and attacking the right
people and we have some enemies in
common who we'll we'll get to shortly uh
but first let's just start with your
story you grew up in Lebanon people
don't know know much about Lebanon tell
me a little bit no they don't and this
is why I am so passionate about this
issue because terrorism affected my life
personally in Lebanon you know people
ask me all the time Bri where does this
passion comes from and I tell them
because terrorism changed my life I was
born into a country Lebanon that used to
be majority Christian country when I was
a child we were open-minded we were Fair
we were tolerant we were Multicultural
we prided ourselves on our
multiculturalism we had open borders
policy we welcomed everyone into our
country because we wanted to share with
them the westernization which we had
created in the heart of the Middle East
Muslims used to send their children to
study in our universities they graduated
and worked in our economy because we had
built the best economy in the Middle
East yeah Didn't They Call barut Beirut
was the Paris of the Middle East or
something Paris of the Middle East
exactly unfortunately all that began to
change as the Muslims became the
majority and the Christians became the
minority and that's when my life life
changed I remember we used to go to
Beirut for Christmas to visit with the
rest of my family I lived in the South
with my parents and I would and we
stopped going and I would ask my father
why we're not going to the family for
Christmas or Easter and he would tell me
Well we decided to stay home this year
and I couldn't understand you know why
we decided to stay home you have to
understand I was an only child to an
elderly couple it was very boring and I
then I later learned that the reason why
we stayed home is because the radical
islamist and Palestinians would set up a
Fly by Night checkpoint and would stop
cars traveling and they would ask people
for their IDs when they would stop them
and in Lebanon our religion is written
on our national ID you are either a
Christian a Muslim or a Jew so when they
find out that you are a Christian they
would get everybody out of their car and
shoot them in Cold Blood it became known
as identity killing at the time um
Thomas fredman talks about it in his uh
book from Beirut to Jerusalem yeah that
changed our lives but really the turning
point was in
1975 when radical islamist blew up my
home bringing it down buring me under
the rubble wounded uh as they shouted
about 10 or 10 years old I ended up in a
hospital for two and a half months and
as I laid in a hospital bed going from
surgery one surgery to another I would
ask my father why did they do this to us
and my father would tell me because we
are Christians the Muslims consider us
infidels and they want to kill us so I
learned since I was a 10-year-old little
girl that I am wanted Dead simply
because I was born into the Christian
faith yeah whether I practiced it or not
it was Irrelevant in my enemy's eyes and
that's why people in America don't
understand they think when people say
especially from the Middle East you know
I'm a Christian or I'm a Muslim in
America they think well I'm a Christian
only if I'm a practicing bible thumper
Holy Roller speaking tongue that makes
me a Christian right right well for us
in our region of the world whether your
practicing or not you belong to the
Christian race or group and that's why
they want to kill you it doesn't matter
whether you practice your religion or
not right even though of course a
religion isn't even a race but you're
you're saying it that way to illustrate
the point that for them it doesn't
matter group in other words if your
grandparents were Christians it doesn't
matter if you have been two generation
atheist you are a Christian that's how
your enemy looks at you Isis alqaeda all
these terrorist organizations all these
radical devout islamists look at you
look at America as a Christian Nation
not because we practice Christianity
look at you as a Christian whether you
practice Christianity or not is
irrelevant right your great great great
great great grandparents were either
Jews or Christian therefore you belong
to either one or or two of that sex
right you could be the biggest Heathen
atheist on the planet they would they
wouldn't like you for that either but
doesn't matter you belong to that you're
an Infidel so it's interesting I think
in the in the couple years that I've
been doing the show the only other
person from Lebanon I've had on is
Professor gadad up in Canada and he's
Jewish and his story is very similar to
yours about when things changed and his
family having to get out and his parents
were kidnapped by PL terrorists they
actually survived which is sort of
incredible and now he fights for a lot
of the same things you fight for I'm
curious though when when Islam was was
increasing in Lebanon because we now see
this in Europe and and partly what's
happening all over the world were people
talking about it were was was your
family like what were the moments that
they thought there's something
culturally happening here that that it's
not the
same we were afraid I I was a child I
was 10 years old when the war started
yeah but I remember my parents trying to
hide and I remember hiding with my
parents in the basement or trying to
flee our neighborhood before we lived
permanently in the bomb shelter yeah uh
because you know I lived in a bomb
shelter underground for S years of my
life from the age of 10 till the age of
17 hiding to survive but we went through
a period of 6 months we would flee our
home in the middle of the night and run
downtown to hide at my cousin's home and
we would hide they had a basement where
nobody could get to it and we were
afraid because we knew that our Muslim
neighbors were turning against us people
who we would used to barbecue with the
weekend before were all of a sudden
massacring us the next weekend yeah so
everything changed so fast and you
didn't know how to it's not that you
didn't know who you can trust because it
enemy turned against neighbor neighbor
turned against neighbor yeah uh once the
call of Islam once the call of jihad was
declared because Lebanon was immediately
divided in two sects the Muslims once
the call of Islam was declared
especially with the Palestinians all the
Muslims went with the Palestinians and
literally the Army split and they took
their from the military bases whoever
drove a tank the Muslims took it home
with them literally home Jes and the
Christians took whatever weapons they
can have and whatever tanks to protect
ourselves and this is how the country
became divided and that's when we
started realizing we were different so
in the midst of all this war you had a a
really strange experience with some
Israelis that kind of changed your
feelings on things can you talk about
that a little bit absolutely when I was
a child when the war broke out even when
I was a child going to school uh we were
taught that Israel is the enemy now at
my home I was never taught hate because
we're Christians we don't teach hatred
plus we have more things in common with
the Jews I mean we share the same Bible
so it's different but by the time I was
a child the M Lebanon was majority
Muslim so the anti-Semitism the hatred
for Israel was Rising especially with
the Palestinian issue especially with
the influx of Palestinians into Lebanon
it was what I heard on television what I
heard on the radio um but when the war
started uh all of a sudden we were
trapped we ended up living in a bomb
shelter and I remember my father saying
all the world Christian nations are
going to come see what's happening to
the Christians and save the Christians
because that's when the Muslims started
massacring the Christians literally and
we thought America's going to come
Australia is going to come Britain is
going to come France is going to come
and nobody came and finally few people
from my town got together and they said
we've got to go to the Israeli border
and beg for help we lived 5 kilometers
from the Israeli border and we knew if
we go to Israel and beg for help the
Jews are not going to slaughter us
because we had more shared values with
them than we had with the Muslims so a
few people from my down go to Israel and
wave down an Israeli Patrol in the
middle of the night and they say listen
we are surrounded by the Muslims and
Palestinians and majority of
Palestinians were Muslims who want to
slaughter us you either come in and help
us or they're going to be at your border
so Israel started coming in the middle
of the night and started bringing
ammunition to the military food for the
children because uh Muslims cut off all
Food Supplies to our towns uh and Israel
would bring literally bomb shelters to
those who did not have bomb shelters
blankets everything and Israel would
take Christian men to Israel and teach
them how to fight because the Christians
were the educated ones and we learned
very quickly David that you can have all
your degrees professional degrees on
your wall your accounting degree your
medical degree your law degree none of
that will do you as they say in Texas
didly squat when you are faced with an
enemy bent on killing you in the name of
Allah yeah so Israel would take groups
of Christians train them how to fight
and this is how we survive
I remember at the age of 13 we have been
living in the bomb shelter for 3
years and one of our militia friends
came by and he said brijit I just want
to tell you that we heard a lot of
chatter on the radio and we're going to
be attacked tonight and he said I don't
think we're going to last I think our
town will fall and he said if I don't
see you tomorrow I wish you a merciful
death and he left and I remember David
at the age of 13 years old putting on my
Sunday Best my Easter dress dress
because I wanted to look pretty when I
am dead because I knew that when they
come to slaughter me there would be no
one to bury me and I remember sobbing as
my mother combed my long black hair down
to my hips and tied the white ribbon in
my hair as I begged her I don't want to
die I'm only 13 years old please I don't
want to die and there was nothing my
mother could say to me and we sat in the
corner of our bomb shelter that night
and my father said to me he said listen
we lived a long life you are young young
child when they come to slaughter us
tonight you just run towards Israel and
you never look back we'll create a
commotion you just run towards Israel
thank God I did not have to make that
decision that night because that's the
night when Israel came in physically
into Lebanon and established the
security Zone and set up artillery bases
around our town to protect us so the
islamists will not be able to come in
and Slaughter us and we went on living
like this until 1982 another 5 years
until Israel invaded Lebanon in 1982 and
Israel invaded Lebanon working with the
Christians in Lebanon trying to help the
Christians take back their democracy
reestablish control of the country and
kick out the radical Islamic element
that had taken control of the country at
that time because by 1982 we had 11
Islamic terrorist organizations
operating out of Lebanon including the
PLO yeah all right so let's pause there
because there there's so much politics
but what obviously shines through is is
your personal story and it's it's so
interesting to me I find this when I
talk to certain guests who've lived
through a lot you talk about a bomb
shelter and it's almost like oh I lived
in a bomb shelter for three years like
it's just it is what it is as opposed to
it's impossible for me to even fathom
what that could be like how much do you
feel like your own story here has sort
of been hijacked I guess that's sort of
a operative word here that for people
like you and Aon and Yasmin Mohammad who
I had on a couple weeks ago people that
have lived through some of this stuff
these stories really don't get told
anymore because they somehow because
you're using all the buzzwords when you
say Muslim or this or that that people
are afraid to talk about this and all
you've done so far is tell your own
personal story right and it's the story
that shapes my life and my Outlook I was
robbed of my childhood people ask me
where does this passion come from Brit I
tell them you know how Holocaust
Survivors walk around with tattoos on
their arms I walk around with scars I
still have shrapnel in my bones this is
what I look at when I take a shower
every morning and I am reminded of what
happens when people turn a blind eye to
evil thinking it's not going to happen
to me I am the an Frank who lived to
tell about it and I'm trying to warn the
world in my situation in my life living
with um crawling under the bombs digging
out grass to eat digging out dandelion
to eat one of my job if you want to call
it jobs in the bomb shelter we lived
with my parents um it was only me and
them in this Hall 6 feet underground No
Sunshine always in the darkness Milo on
the walls literally white buildo covered
the walls and we would sit there dirt
floors and my one of my jobs was
breaking chickpeas old dried chickpeas
that my mother would soak overnight in
water because we didn't have any food
other than and whatever citas would
bring a box of food and I remember we
they had bugs in in the chickpeas and my
job was to break the Chickpea in half
and with a little needle take the bugs
out and put them on the side of the dish
so we can eat the chickpeas um I
remember sleeping I had long hair and I
remember as a child people see me today
and they think this glamorous lady and
they think oh wow what a life you know
they don't realize what carved the
character of the person you see today I
remember as a child sleeping on on the
floor on the dirt and getting lice in my
hair and I remember my mother putting
kerosene on my head so it will kill the
lies and combing my hair and I remember
closing my nose and my eyes are burning
and my mother would say it's okay this
will kill the lies and this became our
life we went from as a child as an only
child to a successful businessman with a
living servant and a chauffeur to drive
me to school was sitting with my parents
breaking chickpeas with bugs digging out
for dandelion to eat and my mother
coming lice out of my hair by killing it
by putting kerosene or Mazo or Benzene
on my
head uh we didn't have any medication I
don't drink alcohol people ask me all
the time oh why don't you drink it they
think it's a religious thing well the
bomb shelter because my father owned the
restaurant the bomb shelter was the
storage room for all the liquor and wine
because obviously 6 feet underground
it's temperature
controlled and we didn't have have any
medication and we didn't have any
doctors to go to the hospital was bombed
out and we used alcohol as medication so
when I would be sick once a month and I
didn't have any pills or any medication
and and I would be in extreme terrible
pain and my father would pour me a shot
of whiskey Johnny Walker 777 and he
would say oh honey just drug it this
will take your pain away so in my mind
as an adult I associate alcohol with
medicine wow so I don't even drink
anything um it changes your life um New
Year's Eve I I I took me 50 years to
figure out why I cry every New Year's
Eve why I feel utter sadness come into
me as people get so excited at midnight
M and I couldn't put my finger on it
people would be so jubilant and so
excited and and I would look around and
I would always tear up and I learned the
scars of War growing up in a bomb
shelter when you don't have anything to
smile about or laugh about in your
formulative
years you don't know how to be happy
those wires that connect people excited
and learning how to be happy as you're
developing as your brain is developing
to know what it's really to be happy
happy happy that that exuberant Joy
where people are just let loose and be
happy I don't have that I was robbed of
that so when I would watch people on New
Year's Eve being so happy that's when it
hit me that I couldn't get that happy
and I didn't know why and I couldn't
even recognize it until I got to be 50
years old to I started learning about my
background and what shaped me those are
the untold stories that people do not
want to bother hearing it's like when
you talk to Holocaust Survivors they
they they come here they're successful
they're brilliant they own great
businesses like Lebanese like like me I
I am living the American dream I made
lemonade out of lemon like Holocaust
like many Holocaust stories you hear
yeah and you don't hear the details
because people do not want to bother
hearing
what shaped the person to become the
stroke person to be able to move forward
in life and become productive and do
great things in life and become
philanthropist and change the world and
make it a better place and put a smile
and and and shine Joy to the World even
though you're you're dealing sometimes
with hard issues like I do yeah so let's
get to that part because that's the
that's the part of you that I know as
the public person is this exuberant
person who's passionate about what they
do and smiles and all this stuff making
up for L time yeah yeah that that's
great though that's what it's all about
right so when did you come to America
and how quickly did you realize how
great things are here it seemed even
right now when I say that things are
great here I always know there's a
certain amount of people in America that
are oh he's what he's being just a blind
Patriot saying things are great in
America but as someone that lived
through some yeah can you say
things are great here oh my God America
is God's gift to the universe there is
no place better than America uh actually
I ended up moving to Israel not to
America I ended up living in Israel from
1984 till 1989 wow I somehow I missed
that part in the bio so how did you get
there you got to read my story I've got
a book titled because they hate for
those of us for for people who are
watching us right now they can get the
book and read my story it's my Memoir
because they hate fantastic it's a great
encouraging story about the tri of the
human spirit so after we came out of the
bomb shelter when Israel invaded Lebanon
my mother became wounded we ended up
going to an Israeli hospital where I
spent 22 days with her and those days
changed my life it made me realize
Israelis were completely different than
anything I heard about and I vowed that
one day I will go back to Israel and I
end up moving to Israel in 1984 and
becoming news anchor for world news in
the Middle East in the 80s covering
world events and Reporting on world
events and um and actually you know as I
reported on world events I started
realizing there was a pattern developing
because no matter where the terrorist
activity took place the name of the
perpet traitors were always Muslims
Ahmed Muhammad Hussein Ali the name of
the victims were always westerners
Christians and Jews Terry W Terry
Anderson Colonel Higgins the achil lowo
the TWA flights I can go on and on and I
started
realizing that what I used to think was
a regional problem where a a a majority
Muslim Middle East trying to kill or
expel the minority Christians and Jews
had become a worldwide problem but the
world was not paying attention anyway
from Israel I met an American war
correspondent and we fell in love and we
got married and that's how I left Israel
and came to America and I came to the
United States in 1989 yeah so you get to
the United States I get to America and
even though you had been living in a
democracy now I know that for a couple
years it's a completely different
democracy here and the plurality of
people we have here and all of that
stuff the opportunity in America is
incredible it's incredible we came here
and we started our own business at TV
production company so I remember when we
were starting our own business we went
to the Chamber of Commerce and there is
score which is retired Executives who
actually consult with you on how to
start your own business and I remember
going there and you can sit with them
and these are retired CEOs who would
advise you who will Mentor you on and
this is how you start your own business
this is what you need to do this is the
capital you need to raise and they would
literally hold your hand and the Chamber
of Commerce had brochures and I'm
remember looking at my ex-husband and I
I remember looking at him and
saying it's for free are you tell
they're going to teach you how to start
your own business and I started learning
about America and how it operates the
opportunities in America you can be
anyone you want to be the sky is the
limit there is no excuse yeah none
whatsoever even today even those who are
coming here today to this country the
the opportunities are Limitless it's
incredible but I thought we're an evil
patriarchal racist Society that's bent
on white supremacy or something am I am
I wrong on that have I made a mistake
absolute baloney listen I came to this
country in
1989 and I had my own TV production
company I worked so many jobs you know I
I have never felt as a second class
citizen or persecuted or that I am
different in any way shape or form
whatsoever yeah uh America is an amazing
place um America is a land if there was
ever a place where anyone can belong
it's America because we came here from
everywhere and everybody from all walks
of life whether your father was a
janitor your father was a Mega
millionaire you come to America and you
have a fresh start fresh identity nobody
cares what your father's title is It's
what you make of yourself and you can be
anything you want to be this is America
it's amazing I'm so fortunate to live
here yeah I lived in New York City most
of my life and when I go back now every
time I go on the subway I just look
around for a second and you quite
literally see everybody every shade
color religion ethnicity nationality and
even if we're not all constantly uh
fawning over each other we live together
just that in and of itself is an
incredibly beautiful thing as someone
that comes from a place that
unfortunately saw the reverse of that
yeah America is different and I can tell
you I was in Europe um I go to Europe um
and uh so two years ago I took my
children on a cruise in Europe and we
went and we cruised around and
everything and we missed so so much
Coming to America you know what we miss
the most being able to have the variety
of food that we have in America all in
one street you walk down one Street in
America you can go one night eat Chinese
one night eat Japanese one night eat
Lebanese one night eat Italian I mean
one night eat Tha the variety America is
so rich in culture that truly melted
into one pot it's very different than
anywhere else in the world so it's not
cultural appropriation when I eat
Chipotle that's supposed to be that way
I'm telling you this this is in America
is an amazing place to live and to
thrive and anybody can come here and
Thrive all right so let's let's pause
for a second and and shift sort of to
your politics before we go into some
other stuff because from the the critics
of yours they she's a right-wing maniac
and she's a right hardcore right-wing
blah blah blah now people are saying
that about me too and and I find you WR
rightwing crazy you yeah and it becomes
it means nothing it just means that
you're not a complete leftist whatever
so they say you're you're a rightwing
whatever um we chatted for just a second
before we started and basically said
you're you're socially liberal and what
what what's thought of as right with you
is just that you care about National
Security is that pretty much yeah I'm a
national I'm a 911 National Security
conservative um you know the New York
Times did an interview with me uh for my
second book title they must be stopped
and you know I mentioned in it that I
voted for Al Gore and a lot of my
friends were like you voted for Al Gore
I said yeah I'm a 911 conser
conservative uh 9/11 made people realize
that we are fighting for the survival of
our civilization we are dealing with
people that want to kill us the national
security issue is an American issue it's
not a republican issue it's not a
democratic issue it's not a Libertarian
issue it's an American issue America has
been attacked under different
Administration by radical Islam
regardless of the politics of whoever
was living at the White House America
was a attacked the first time under the
Carter Administration in 1979 a Democrat
with the hostages in Iran America was
attacked again under Ronald Reagan
administration a republican in 1983 with
the blowing up of the Marines in Lebanon
America was attacked under George Bush
Senior Administration America was
attacked under the Clinton
Administration the first bombing of the
World Trade Center in
1993 was under President Clinton a
Democrat it was actually under President
Clinton that the talibans trained 10,000
Al-Qaeda members in Afghanistan now
these people were not being trained for
entertainment they were trained to
attack the United States of America
America was attacked under George Bush
Junior Administration a republican on
9/11 the only difference between the
attacks of 1993 and 2001 is the
buildings didn't come down and then
people thought if we just elect
President Obama all our sins are going
to be forgiven the whole world is going
to sink onaya yeah obviously that did
not happen so do you do you think that's
his biggest failure that when he gave
that Cairo speech and it was sort of the
reset of this whole thing that he he
sort of offered an apology for America's
foreign policy and whatever else and
that it bought us no Goodwill it didn't
do anything and actually and then you
can argue about the red line in Syria
and a whole bunch of other things that
when we're quote unquote nicer even
though he was at War every day of his
presidency in Afghanistan and drone
strikes in Pakistan and all that stuff
that the the niceties just don't fly in
real ity no because it's not about ni
cities we are dealing with an enemy bent
on our destruction because of their
ideology and as a matter of fact
President Obama was work he did not
understand the Middle East um
or was complicit working with the Muslim
Brotherhood because he thought they they
are a moderate organization actually the
person that wrote President Obama's
speech which he delivered in Cairo the
first major speech to the Arabic world
was written by the head of isna the
president of isna the Islamic Society of
North America which is an unindicted
co-conspirator in the largest terrorism
trial ever in the history of the United
States in 19 um uh in 2007 2008 which
took place in Dallas Texas the Holy Land
Foundation versus our government or our
government versus The Holy Land
foundation so this happened immediately
before he came into office and he
started working with the Muslim
Brotherhood he actually forced president
Mubarak who was our Ally because we got
the majority of our intelligence out of
Egypt and Jordan other than Israel and
he literally threw Mubarak under the bus
and forced Mubarak to accept having the
Muslim Brotherhood leadership in the
first two rows uh attending his speech
in Cairo yeah to the shin of mabarak
because he wasn't understanding what was
going on and he basically empowered them
to basically become so belligerent um
and Advance their cause so do you think
Mubarak saw the writing on the wall then
that he was on his way out no matter
what you think he knew absolutely
because it wasn't terer Square was a
couple years later but at that point
Obama basically said he has to step down
then they then they democratically
elected the Muslim Brotherhood and then
it was worse for a year and now they
have sort of another version of Mubarak
Obama undermined Mubarak and Mubarak
knew it because Mubarak knew how close
Obama was working with the Muslim
Brotherhood and Mubarak knew that the
Muslim Brotherhood is a terrorist
organization you know they are
classified in Egypt as a terrorist
organization they assassin they verified
on Twitter I don't know if you know
they've got the blue check the Muslim
Brotherhood on Twitter they're a
terrorist organization in Egypt but yeah
but not here you know they assassinated
President saddad who signed the peace
treaty for Israel and killed him because
he signed the peace treaty with Israel
that's how Mubarak came to power and
Mubarak had his thumb on them so Obama
thought oh Mubarak is a dictator he's
got his thumb down on these wonderful
people who are just trying you know to
express their opinion um America did not
understand the Middle East so Mubarak
knew what was coming and Obama
emboldened them yeah okay so let's pause
on the musim Brotherhood stuff because
you've given an incredible speech about
that that has about a million views and
it's I would highly recommend that
everyone watch it we'll link to that as
well uh but the the Egypt one is an
interesting one to me because it shows
sort of the the crappy situation we
found oursel in that Mubarak even though
I can see you you support him in certain
ways he obviously wasn't a great guy and
was doing a lot of things against the
press and he he was run he was ruling
via the military but then they got worse
it was worse for the democratically
elected year of the Muslim Brotherhood
so what what then is a sensible solution
you know what I mean if if the choices
are between military and then a
democratically elected group that's
going to be worse than the military what
is a sensible option for a country like
Egypt that is you know really right in
the thick of this thing well the answer
lies Back 40 years and what happened in
the East in the 60s that's when we start
and' 70s that's when we started seeing
uh the Muslim Brotherhood strengthen and
remember the Sha of Iran Iran was a very
liberal Society Afghanistan was very
liberal Society it's incredible see the
pictures of women back then at
universities that were dressed like
westerners absolutely like westerners
Egypt was a liberal Society Syria was a
liberal Society now Iraq was a liberal
Society so when you look at these
so-called what we call dictators who had
their thumb like the Shah in Iran having
his thumb down on the followers um the
Shah knew that these are the radical
islamists who want to establish the
Islamic caliphate they want to resurrect
the caliphate they do not want to have
anything to do with westernization they
want to oppress women they want to put
women in shadur they want men to grow
beards they were the radical ones so you
have people like the Shah or ha Assad
before Bashar now the son yeah remember
H Assad the father killed 30,000 of them
in hamah in Syria in the 70s 30,000
Muslim Brotherhood radical Islam is
trying to rise in Syria saddad did the
same thing to them in Egypt the Shah
tried to do the same thing to them in
Iran so they were Rising all over the
Middle East wanting to establish the
caliphate wanting to bring back what we
have today in Iran under or under Isis
right now uh what they're doing or what
hallah is doing in Lebanon with the
radicalization and we did did not
understand what these liberal leaders we
thought of them as
dictators but they had to be what they
had to be in trying to thumb put their
thumb down on the radicals right it's
funny you describe them as liberal but
in in that sense they were liberal maybe
not by our Western standards but they
were there was some movement there at
least right right but if you talk to
anybody in the Middle East back then
whether it was sadad Sadat signed the
peace treaty with Israel King Hussein
signed the peace treaty with Israel now
it takes a liberal lead to be able to
think I do not want to have anything to
do with that radicalism I want to reach
out and sign a peace treaty and now look
how the deterioration of the situation
whether in Jordan looking Abdullah has
2% support yeah that's it um how much of
them without getting too far into the to
the Israel part of this because that
because that could take us another 27
days um how much do they just sort of
need the hatred of Israel so like the
two most stable states in the Middle
East are Jordan and Egypt it's not a
coincidence that they have peace
treaties but how much do these countries
just need the idea of a conflict and
then perpetuate it so for example in
Jordan you know they say there's
anywhere from 40 to 70% of the
jordanians are actually Palestinians who
don't have equal rights or in Lebanon
aren't there something like 40 or so
jobs that Palestinians aren't allowed to
have and they have trouble getting
citizenship and all that like they need
this conflict to to uh keep the eye off
what their own governments are doing
they don't need the conflict they can
get the jobs they want they can grow
they can accomplish except I can tell
you about Lebanon my own experience in
Lebanon in in the refugee camps in the
Palestinian refugee camps when I don't
mean the Palestinians in the refugee
camps need the conflict I mean the
governments need it because they have to
keep everyone focused on Israel instead
of dealing with what's going on the
Middle East they do not want Israel in
the Middle East but you have to
understand the Middle East is majority
Muslim and the Jews are classified in
the Quran as neus yeah the word nus in
Arabic means filth filth is dogs that's
why Muslims hate dogs they think is nous
bodily fluid uh feis that's nous the
prophet Muhammad on his death bed on his
death bed his last statement commanding
the Muslims to fight the Jews and kill
them until the day of judgment that's
Prophet Muhammad's last commandment
because he was poisoned by a Jewish
woman three years earlier so in the
Muslim mind the Jews will are Eternal
enemies they do not belong in the Middle
East because they are soiling Arab land
that's why they want them out so Israel
could could withdraw out of all of
Israel and leave only mulah just a
sliver the Arabs will not be happy with
that they're going to go after mitula
trying to kill every last Jew yeah
that's the problem it's not about
geography it's about
ideology and that's the problem that
people in the west don't understand okay
so speaking of ideology so now we we've
mentioned the Muslim Brotherhood a bit
as I said you gave this incredible
speech about it for people that don't
really understand what it is at all can
you sort of do Muslim Brotherhood 101
and what this ideology that's really
spreading across the world right now is
is up to ah well the Muslim Brotherhood
is the oldest uh Islamic terrorist
organization in the world it was founded
in 1928 in Egypt uh by a group of mulas
uh and that was and today the Muslim
Brotherhood has 70 offshoot Islamic
organizations including Al-Qaeda Hamas
and also Isis uh you know El zawahiri
who was now the head of uh Al-Qaeda was
imprisoned and exiled from Egypt as a
leader of the Muslim Brotherhood Al
bagdadi the head of Isis right now was a
member of the Muslim Brotherhood in our
prisons as early as 200 uh 11 uh because
he was a member of the Muslim
Brotherhood so the Muslim Brotherhood
its members are the most highly educated
members they are the lawyers they are Al
zahiri is a surgeon Al bagdadi is a PhD
has a PHD in Islamic theology uh Usama
Bin Laden was a a a businessman engineer
Muhammad ATA the ring leader of the
September 11th attack was in engineer so
the Muslim Brotherhood was founded I
thought this was about poverty that's
what people on the left will always say
it's about poverty if they just had the
same opportunity it has nothing to do
with poverty it has to do with ideology
uh this is why you see people like Usama
Bin Laden leaving all their wealth all
their Millions on going living in a cave
in Afghanistan this is why you see Al
zawahiri a surgeon living in a hell hole
in Afghanistan this is why you see
people like Muhammad ATA or zad Zarah
the second the ring Le the second in
command of the 9911 attack blow
themselves up he was a doctor it has
nothing to do with money see we in the
west think if you have the swimming pool
the Mercedes the nice big house and the
nice zip code why would you want to kill
yourself because we are judging
everything according to Western values
but the Muslim Brotherhood was a
response to the ending of the caliphate
by Ator in 1924 in Turkey when president
atur gave rights to women to vote gave
rights to women to in education gave
rights women to choose whatever they
want to do whoever they want to marry so
the Muslim Brotherhood was launched and
when it was launched people thought oh
Islam is over Islam will never be
resurrected so the Muslim Brotherhood
kept growing and growing and growing and
organizing and two things happened in
the Middle East that made the islamist
explode worldwide the discovery of oil
in the Middle East and then aah Ki
coming to power in
1979 that gave them the money and the
spiritual covering to explode on the
world stage in 1982 the Muslim
Brotherhood wrote a plan a 100-year plan
for radical Islam to infiltrate and
dominate the west and establish an
Islamic government on Earth yeah and
this is what your videoos about that
I've been mentioning and the in the
counterterrorism circles the plan became
known as the project and what makes the
project so unique is it gives tactics
and proposals as to how to use our
open-mindedness against us how to use
our multiculturalism against us they
even talk about certain words that will
make questioners lay down their guard
words like uh
diversity tolerance
multiculturalism inner Faith um does
that sound familiar um right now I mean
the word islamophobia which is a
completely nonsensical idea no one's
afraid of the of the word you know Islam
as an ideology you're afraid of what the
adherence might do right right exact and
by the way islamophobia was concocted at
the United Nations by a group of Muslim
organizations saying well we need to
vilify anybody who's going to about
Islam or criticize uh Islam well we in
the west debate I mean people like us
who come from the judeo-christian world
the Bible says come let's reason
together in Judaism they have uh people
that go to Seminary all they do all day
long is debate that's their job and I
don't and that being said I don't think
that anything that we're doing here is
based in any sort of biblical anything
you're you're giving me you're giving me
secular thoughts on hisor events
absolutely exactly uh you know but so
the Muslim brother Hood started
exploding and they started in this plan
talking about how to get democratically
Muslim uh elected to the West on all
levels of the West uh how to get U
Muslim interns and governmental offices
so they can have an insid review as to
how policy is done on the highest levels
they talk about how to work with
like-minded organizations Progressive
organizations that share similar goals
this is why when you see the ACU working
with care you scratch your head and you
think to yourself how can these two
people work together you've got a
radical Lefty organization you know Pro
gay pro abortion Pro this Pro that
you've got the islamist on the other
hand but the ACLU is being used as the
useful idiots at the hands of people
like care so that is incredibly obvious
to me I mean that it that what they're
doing this is intersectionality this is
the idea that we're all sort of
oppressed now we happen to like gays and
women and for care or for some of these
other organizations we're going to
pretend as long as we need to so that we
can gain power I think that's a great
transition to your good friend Linda
sarur let's sarur by the way what does
it mean in Arabic uh s cockroach
cockroach cockroach okay I like he had
to think for a second cockroach okay so
let's talk about this woman because
she's become a hero of the left I see
Bernie tweeting you know I stand with
Linda I've seen people like van Jones
claiming that her critics are bigots um
she she really does not like you I mean
she's she had a tweet from a couple
years ago that was genuinely threatening
you if you if you were to live in her
City um which maybe we'll we'll put the
Tweet up uh and then she tweeted perhaps
the most vile thing that I've seen on
Twitter which was something to the
effect of that she would take away that
women like you like brigit and Ian her
Al don't deserve their vaginas and that
she would take them away now of course
she knows that ion has underwent female
genital mutilation uh that ion has lived
her whole life to defend the Western
principles that you're talking about
here so this is pretty obvious to anyone
that knows anything about this it's
clear to me what she's doing she does
not care about these women's
organizations and yet she's lauded as a
hero of the women's rights movement
while they're out there in vagina hats
what is going on here Linda sarur is a
very smart woman I have to give her that
because she is a master manipulator
knowing exactly how to manipulate the
gullies to advance her cause Linda sarur
wants Sharia law if if it was a to her
to be the law of the land in the United
States as a matter of fact she tweeted
many times about how wonderful sharah is
how lucky women in Saudi Arabia to live
under Shar just because they have
maternity leave much better than us did
you see the response from the Israeli
Ambassador or something like that it was
brilliant she said saying about how well
under Sharia law in Saudi Arabia they
have three months maternity leave the
Israeli Ambassador Rob back he said well
our women have four months and they can
drive yeah oh I like that I like that
yeah but what she doesn't mention is
that these women in Saudi Arabia yeah
they may have maternity leave but they
were did were they impregnated by
consensual sex or were they raped by
their husbands were they beaten into
having sex by their husband were they
you know this is where the touchy
subject that Americans don't feel
comfortable talking about even uh on
television or radio or anywhere I think
we can be more open even talking on the
internet because this is an internet
show um where we can actually talk about
you know semi- truth we can't even be
too open um but women in Saudi Arabia
are nothing but Shadow that's what the
Quran talks about women women are
secondhand they're they're the the
Hadith says women are like your field
plow into them as if you plow into your
field treat them like barn animals the
Quran looks at women as a material
object to you to be used for pleasure
and to be used to take care of the
household the clean basically a woman is
a servant a cleaner a factory for making
babies and taking care of the babies
that's it and supplying the pleasure for
for the husband um the husband can
divorce her by saying three words your
divorce your divorce you're divorced and
that's said she's divorced um no papers
required the woman have no right a
woman's testimony testimony is worth
half of that of a man so this is the
type of world that Linda sarur want
women in the United States to live under
but but the glial women's movement in
the United States who came out they hate
the conservative mov M so much because
the conservative movement is shining a
light on what Islam is all about and
because they have gone out of their way
to defend um everything on the left and
the Islamic agenda that in order for
them to start even looking at what
Sharia La is and how women are treated
will basically make them Liars with egg
on their face that they have fought
actually to protect these rights so they
just ignore it completely they don't
talk about it so when you see at the
women's March these women wearing the
hijab or this that picture of the the
girl in the ncab in an American flag
ncab which I I've mentioned this before
I was in West Hollywood a couple weeks
ago which is quite literally the gayest
place on Earth and there was a bunch of
gay guys that sell mannequins and the
one they were all naked except the one
they had dressed was in was the ncab and
I thought you guys you're in the gayest
place on Earth the freest place on Earth
to do whatever you want with your life
and you're fetishizing something that
would that would undermine your entire
life if not destroy your entire so when
you see hijab at the at the women's
March and all that and knowing what you
came from it must absolutely enrage you
oh it's very sad it saddens me because
when I see what the American public is
trying to sell our daughters and our
future Generations as acceptable without
recognizing the ramification of it
because Americans are not seeing the
ramification when you start seeing hijab
popping into a community that's a sign
of radicalization that's not a sign of
of progressiveness it's a sign of going
backward that's actually the first sign
of a radicalization of a community
because that means they're becoming more
devout more following uh the Quran to
the letter oppressing woman a woman in a
hijab means you are shameful to look at
you are dirty to look at therefore you
need to be covered because you are a
walking sin so if I am tempted to look
at you or to rape you you made me rape
you because you made me see your ankle
because it flashed a little bit under
the hijab and therefore you deserve to
be raped or you deserve to be beaten or
you deserve to be abused what message
are we sending our daughters yeah so you
basically think that there's there's
malicious intent with sarur herself but
basically the the other groups the the
gay groups and the women's groups and
these other Progressive groups they're
just being they just don't know what
they're doing basically they just I
would assume some of them do have bad
intentions I think but I would argue
that most of them just don't even
understand this this Alliance that
ultimately will eat itself you can't say
you're for Muslims and for gay people if
those people have competing things now I
would hope that most of them would
forget any of their prejudices and just
live together but the idea of we're for
this group and this group it throws out
all of the individuals right we've got
we've got to be able to look at the
problem we are facing as a society we
all came to America America is a melting
po we all came from all over the world
we came here because we loved everything
America stands for you know I may
disagree with this person passionately I
may disagree with Linda sarur
passionately but I will fight to the
desk to make sure that she has the right
to say what she needs to say even though
it makes my skin crawl she has the right
to do that and look at me I I can't even
speak on college campuses I mean the
last college campus I spoke at was the
University of Detroit at an arbor I had
to have nine security officers and a K9
unit to sniff the auditorium for bombs
an hour before I spoke yeah and that's
an American University all right you
want to find a university we can go to
together let's find one we can go to
together and just see what happens can
you I would love can you imagine you
when I on the road as a team a
conservative uh National Security expert
and you as a gay conservative on
National Security uh people you know
don't expect people like us to come out
and stand for what we believe in and
that is the protection of our country
that's what we care about people are
welcome to come here pray to whatever
God they want build whatever house of
worship they want we are all for that
our constitution gives them the right to
do that I don't care what rocks you
believe in as long as you don't throw
those rocks at me wanting to kill me
yeah you know that's what America is all
about so we need to shine a light on the
problems and we need our people all
Americans to develop the backbone to
start saying let's step back and look at
the problem that's threatening all of us
under Sharia law gays are thrown off of
buildings women are stoned to death
women are whipped uh you know if they
are seen cuz a man or if they are
impregnated out of woodlock or whatever
the case may be women are forced to
marry um women are allowed to be raped
and even in their marriages is this
really what we want in our society uh a
woman can be raped and she needs four
witnesses to basically um for the judge
to agree with her that she actually was
raped for male Witnesses and by the way
we are seeing this leak into Western
Society just in the last couple weeks
there's been a bunch of stories about
for the first time people are being
arrested because of FGM here in the
United States that's right yeah but on
the protest front now protest in and of
itself is fine but how how is this all
connected to what's happening with the
left like this need to silence everybody
so that for someone like you to not be
able to go to a college campus what is
that I mean that must for you knowing
from where you came has got to be pretty
scary thought uh it is a scary thought
because I value freedom because I come
from tyranny I know what it's like to be
muzzled uh and not be able to say what
you need to say l you be killed where I
come from any country in the Middle East
I don't care how liberal it is Jordan
Egypt so I'm going to give you the top
two liberal countries in the Middle East
Jordan and Egypt yeah if you say
anything against the king or you
demonstrate against the king or you
don't agree with something against
whatever leader you are literally
rounded on the street corner and thrown
in jail period your family will never
hear from you again you are tortured you
are beaten you are raped you are
sodomized whatever it is nobody will
come to your Aid and that's Jordan and
Egypt so I understand how valuable it is
to be able to come together and
demonstrate and protest and express our
opinion freely and we are losing that in
our country and the irony is we are
losing that because the left who
supposedly stands for tolerance and
multiculturalism and open-mindedness and
fairness are muzzling our speech to be
able to say what we need to say and let
people decide for themselves right
because your story should be a story
that the left would love because you you
are dark skinned yeah you've come from
oppression you now are you're a feminist
and that you are I don't know if you
consider yourself a I am a feminist
absolutely I was say you're a woman
you're for yourself and for other women
okay but all of those things they they
should love your story and by the way
what you're saying about about Jordan uh
we just did a fan show where I
interviewed 20 people from all over the
world and I interviewed a bisexual guy
in Jordan who was happy to show his face
he said there are there are gay bars
there and he said the one thing that you
can't he said he's not you know fully
out out like that but he said that the
real risk is that it's not that you
would say something about the government
that you'd say something about the
monarchy which is exactly what you just
said so so I I just I'm illustrating
that just you're not you're not
exaggerating here you're making the
point no I mean and those are the
government when you look at the Middle
East you can identify I mean now things
are changing but back up until 10 years
ago when you look at the Middle East
you're looking at tribes with flags
those countries which we call countries
it's tribes with flags you can identify
every country by one one royal family
and or One dictator Saudi Arabia the
royal family Jordan the royal family uh
Syria Assad uh Iraq used to be Saddam
Hussein I mean Egypt Mubarak before him
was saddad I mean literally yeah every
country by one royal family which is
basically the government uh and so we
need to protect freedom of speech in
America it is the most valuable thing we
have because they're losing it in Canada
they lost it in Canada they are losing
it all over the world and we cannot
allow what's happening in Europe to
happen in our country that's why I
launched act for America my organization
we are now the largest national security
Grassroots movement in the United States
with over half a million members and
over 1,000 chapters Nationwide and and I
encourage people who are watching us to
join us become active uh become involved
our members are Christians Jews atheist
Buddhist Hindus gays lesbians people who
put their you got some Muslims in there
too oh yeah yeah absolutely and we have
moderate Muslims speak at our national
conference every year of course the left
never covers that you know um but we are
people who are bringing Americans
together and we're having a march on
June 10th um coming up it's March
against Sharia # March against Sharia
and we already have 17 cities scheduled
to have this March and we haven't even
announced it I'm actually this is the
first place I speak about it great and
uh we want people because it coincides
with the shooting at the Orlando uh
against the gay club uh it also now with
FGM we are calling FGM month uh the
month of May to shine a light on what's
happening in the country half a million
girls in America are subjected and under
the danger of undergoing female genital
mutilation according to CDC either have
gone or are there risk of going the
female genital mutilation yeah and the
feminists in the left just simply won't
touch this and meanwhile a conservative
right-wing Maniac is going to is going
to right but we are organizing these
marches anybody who wants to get
involved and March with us go to our
website uh act for america.org send us
an email put March against Sharia and
get involved for more information in
your city so do you see the best way to
counter this is is purely just the free
speech thing I mean we can we can talk
about the ins and outs all the time and
we can try to expose people like sarur
and the rest of this but that truly that
the sword that we all have to die on is
the free speech thing is that really the
the only answer to this it's it's the
only answer that I can come up with
which is why I do the show the way I do
it but free speech and activism our sign
doesn't act they sit around and say oh
my God I can't believe they're doing
this at Sanford how could they do such a
thing our side doesn't show up and
demonstrate our side doesn't show up and
really come together to in a show of
force by presence you know show up on
the streets the left shows up by the
thousands the tens of thousands we do a
rally you see 100 people show up we need
more people showing up we need more
people active and engaged and that's why
we named the organization Act for
America not think about America not hope
for America not wish for America but act
for America because without action
nothing happens uh we have a National
Conference coming up in Washington DC
October uh I encourage people to go to
our website and find out more
information about it act conon 2017 our
national conference we have 16 members
of Congress every year speak at our
national conference it's the largest
gathering of Americans of all background
meeting with elected officials coming on
Washington DC to remind the officials
National Security is important we are
fighting for the preservation of our
judeo-christian culture where everybody
can be free everybody can do whatever
they want to do as long as they respect
the Constitution and agree that everyone
is equal under the law yeah it's
interesting to me that you make that
distinction that you're talking about
judeo-christian culture but what you're
really asking for is that we just be
governed by our laws you're not being
you're not and there there's I think a
lot of people even atheists have a
struggle with this the idea that our
foundation sort of is judeo-christian
but you're not you're not asking that
anyone be governed under the Old
Testament or the this is purely a purely
cultural purely secular when you look at
Western Civilization western
civilization was founded on
judeo-christian principles don't call
them the Ten Commandments call them
principles you know do unto others what
you want others to do unto you we are
raised with that whether we're
practicing Christians or not my children
were raised without the mention of God
in my household complete atheists they
know anything about the Bible they
didn't know I didn't have a Bible in the
household nothing my children were
raised with do unto others what you want
others to do unto you be kind forgive
your enemy forgive those who trespass
against you you're above holding a
crudge move forward in Li just release
them focus on the good make good Focus
your energy on making the world a better
place those are judeo-christian
principles yes they are founded in the
Bible but they are judeo-christian
principles that everybody in the West
Western World lives and abides by and we
are truly facing a clash of cultures
right now yeah so so speaking of that
Clash of cultures I thought I'd do you a
little favor here because when I was
doing research about you if I look at
your Wikipedia not that I trust I mean I
don't trust anyone's Wikipedia But there
is this constant theme that you're
somehow anti-muslim that you're an
anti-muslim bigot or something to that
effect so I thought I would give you the
chance to say something about Muslim
people I know you make the distinction
between Islam as a set of IDE as you've
already you know briefly mentioned this
and the people uh but if you say
something publicly maybe we can counter
a little of the Wikipedia cuz I don't
sense bigotry from you I send someone
that's fighting for values consistently
whether the bad ideas were coming from
Jews or Christians or wherever else no
so let's clean it up and see if someone
puts this on Wikipedia CLE you know
Wikipedia you know anybody can say
anything they want on Wikipedia so never
ever believe wedia because it's a bunch
of Lies we talk to them we try to change
the profile they will go back
immediately some lefties and they we
change it back to whatever they want to
frame see they're trying to frame people
like you and me in a certain way this is
the war of ideas right now and they are
trying to smear our reputation by coming
up with their own language I am not
anti-muslim I am anti- ideology that
wants to kill free people and subjugate
them in the name right now in the name
of the Islamic religion I don't I would
fight with the same passion if crazy
Christians were trying to do that or
crazy Jews were trying to do that or
whatever crazy religion is trying to do
that I am for the human Spirit and the
individuality of the human spirit I am
the perfect example of a woman who was
raised in a bomb shelter a feminist who
came to America is living the American
dream started her own business I am all
I can be as a person and trying to be
better and trying to make the world a
better place I love people there are
Muslims in this world who do not want to
have anything to do with the radicals do
not want to kill any anybody have never
even read the Quran and I'll give you
this I I'll I tell you this my daughter
just had a baby my daughter named her
baby lla after her Muslim best friend so
my granddaughter is named after her
Muslim best friend who was with us on
Easter Sunday just a couple weeks ago
baptizing my
grandchild and who is from Pakistan so
you tell me am I a racist who ha all
Muslims which is absolute nonsense you
know but this is how the left is
attacking us the best thing we can do is
move forward doing what we do work with
moderate Muslims who love the West as
much as we do who love our values as
much as we do who love our culture as
much as we do and work together to
defend our culture against the radicals
who want to kill us all yeah do you
think that there's something
particularly perverse with the left now
like for someone like me that's kind of
only in this for the last couple years
and I I used to be a progressive and
then I saw what was going on does it
seem worse to you now or am I just kind
of new to this over the last couple
years like 10 years ago do you think it
was this this bad or the or just that
the plans maybe hadn't kind of kicked in
yet it was bad but it has gotten worse
it was bad but it was not this violent
and maybe because they had Obama in
office and so they didn't realize it
because people on uh the right on this
specific issue I'm not going to go out
and smash windows and break Windows
because I don't disagree with the
speaker uh when Obama was alive I didn't
agree with Obama but I respected him for
the position that he held and I said
okay here's our president we're going to
give him a chance and what an amazing
country we live in that we were able to
elect a black president this is a
testimony about how great America is I
actually cried and I did not vote for
Obama but I had tears in my eyes
watching the results of the election
even though it was a mixed emotion of
sadness but at the same time joy that we
as a great nation were able to put our
differences aside and be able to elect
despite the history a black president
and we said you know what we're going to
give him the best shot you didn't see
people like me demonstrating breaking
windows so the left right now is so
intolerant is so vicious in their
attacks to the point that if you or me
or Milo or an cter or Ayan hery Ali say
anything about anything we are attacked
physically yeah um and and that's a
shame that we are to this point in our
country all right so just a couple other
things and then we're going to do one
bonus segment with you that part of it
that you've put yourself out there
publicly and that people say bad things
or that you've had to have police take
you at a university or whatever it is
can you just talk about the cost of that
I know I know every public person
doesn't like talking about it but there
is a cost and I can see as you sit here
and smiling and how passionate you are
about all this stuff that it's not
something you focus on but because I
think people ask me about that a lot you
know like what about putting yourself
out there people are afraid to do it but
I my feeling is we need more people I
don't think I'm anyone special I'm one
guy that's doing something that I
believe in but for you just the cost of
the
hate history remembers those who made a
difference and I believe every single
one of us in life has a destiny has a
purpose and every single one of us in
life is shaped by the experiences that
we go through and every experience is a
preparation every experience is a
stepping stone to refine us so we can be
instruments of change as adults in our
world to make the world a better place
some of us recognize their purpose and
some of us live a lifetime without ever
recognizing their purpose but if you do
recognize your purpose and you are
fortunate enough to realize the gifts
that you have been given even though you
have gotten these gifts through going
through hell like I did I know that this
is my opportunity to be able to speak
for my nation and make a difference I
immigrated to the land of the free and
the home of the brave and I wake up
every morning and I thank God and our
founding fathers that I can fight
sitting in my pajamas in front of my
computer and don't have to Brave the
snow and Valley Forge the way our
founding fathers suffered and starved
and froze and some of them died broke
giving their life and putting their life
on the line to give us the freedoms that
we have today the least we can do is
preserve those freedoms for our next
Generation you never really own Freedom
David we only take care of freedom and
preserve it to the next generation and I
am doing my part as an
American as a brave American in the home
of the brave to make sure I follow and
the footsteps of our founding fathers
and do my part as they entrusted me with
that which they have created I feel it
is my duty to make sure to preserve it
to pass it to my children and their
American children and many generations
to come that's why we fight and I am so
fortunate that through this fight and it
is a fight for freedom for liberty for
democracy for security for human rights
I am privileged to meet the most amazing
people that I would never otherwise meet
like sitting here with you
today uh and meet friends that have
become lifelong friends literally like
family to me that I would never have
otherwise met if it wasn't doing for
what I do so do I get depressed doing
what I do talking about terrorism and
National Security of course I do I'm
human like everybody Sometimes I Cry
Sometimes I'm completely depressed over
things that are happening sometimes I
hurt deeply by people who stab me in the
back or say bad things about me or even
reading my Wikipedia profile but what
keeps me so energized is the American
people and the American Spirit knowing
that we are making a difference we are
growing we are changing our country we
are fighting we have a purpose so when
you and I die on our death bed we can
look back and we can say I made a
difference as we take our last breath
and that's enough for me well I actually
had a couple more questions for you but
that that is how you end an interview
we're going to do a little more for our
for our Patron audience and I thank you
for this this was a pleasure and
especially the end I'm I'm feeling very
energized uh for more on brijit and her
work check out you did something no it's
there's a the lights are getting me
uh for more on bri and her work check
out actforamerica.org
[Music]